today on our show holy-shit guardians of
the galaxy to treadeth and we're gonna
watch it you're gonna watch just watch
it like the dirty little cups you are on
today's Batman I'm Batman
[Music]
love the fat man I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith I'm mark Bernardi ah the Guardians
the galaxy trailer mark vol 2 dropped
the other day we have not weighed in on
it know as one should all right but you
know I'll tell you before we got dive in
I've seen it I like it quite a bit yeah
I agree with you I concur yes
so spoilers we're in but we're gonna
watch it together and you're gonna watch
us watch it and we'll talk about it and
stuff like that it is like we all went
to the movies together and you sit down
for the trailers like [ __ ] did
you see that I am down that we're going
it was like we are the irritating people
that talked through the trailer with a
sin Easter like Shh shut up we got
friends you don't I was alone cineast at
one point but now I've got friends we're
doing this all right so we're gonna
watch the guardians of the galaxy vol 2
vol 2 ball 2 trailer here we go make
sure that vines pumped yes
so you get it both ways coming and going
James Gunn son marvel at its finest here
we go I ring it a man oh my god man this
looks beautiful
[ __ ] this looks expensive
[Music]
excellent choice of music once again
visually stunning honey I love it so
much
he's become one of my new fave and how
awesome the flip with him on his bag the
jamming feeling you're in the need of a
hug oh my lord man how pitch perfect is
that each one of these I mean same thing
with the last one every trailer we got
was a little bit better than the last
yeah this was pretty dynamite song
choice excellent it's not quite as good
Shaka as Booga Chaka but it's still
pretty [ __ ] good yeah and some cats
know it's some kids don't whereas
everyone knew who good what else I
wonder if that's been diesel if it's his
voice pitched all the way up to be kid
voice I mean not if he charged the son
like if he was like you know if his
agent was like I'm sorry man you know
it's it's been you got to pay
I'd be like come on dude it's baby grew
[Music]
Mormont's though is pretty damn funny oh
he's like I am group pitch-perfect man
you see something like that it makes you
want to hold on for a few more months
just the side of the bowl as the world
spirals down we got that shit's looking
bleak man James fires his gun and [ __ ]
we get to watch something that makes you
go alright so I'll wait through whatever
is coming next to get to that then I can
die they better have another Marvel
trailer so there it is man me and Mark
watching the trail are you watching us
watch the trailer yeah even more of that
trailer inception yeah it's real
inception that's right cuz that's all it
takes these days man you can watch
somebody else's [ __ ] just be like wow
it's like one but for trailers that's
true it's true man this is kind of like
like a stroke mini stroke clip for
people that like film right and that's
about as long as you need for most
pornography anyway now I get it
oh my god here we are [ __ ] busting
our humps to an hour-long shows you got
to be able to watch your line in the
[ __ ] get it now forget it unless
you've got some intestinal issues and
get you dinner for the whole hour which
is with me I should in the first like 10
seconds and it's been a horrible don't
look at that people like how can you
stand your own steak I'm like my steak
sorry I built it I built this Delta [ __ ]
yes I built this shitty right in
[Music]
that's all we got for today mm-hmm
Batman I'm Batman
I'm Kevin I'm mark no next time
soon we'll be racing us again watching
something else
same bat-time same bat-channel SModcast
comma war youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
[Music]